[Music]
all right so uh yes or no are we fans of
Mariah Care's All I Want for Christmas
Is year I love that song course
abolutely did we talk about this
yesterday though y no okay we mentioned
it cuz it does sound familiar right we
talked about is that song this isn't
that okay no no no go
ahead talk about how we liked it yeah
weal and then some of us were like oh I
I don't like it anymore who didn't like
it said you no it wasn't me who it was K
yeah can sucks little [__] ass he like
it's played out I was like shut up k I
love that song's like then K's like all
music really is beautiful and he's like
but not Mariah Care's [__] total hippie
[__] I guess meditative trans remix I
love that song so apparently all right
um that was uh that was co-written by
her and this other dude named I hope I
pronounce this right Walter
aanf I don't know anyways co-written and
he was basically a musician behind it
and stuff like that right but he's got a
little bit of a gripe because uh more
recently in the last decade or so
apparently the story kind of transcended
where she
started exacer uh exacerbating the way
that it came to
exaggerating Excalibur yes yes yes yeah
that's a cool hotel dude and thank you
oh hold up wait was that Excalibur
Excalibur is in Las Vegas at the very
end of the strip and it's kind of like
medieval times but it's like next level
Medieval Times Next Level because it's
like medieval times but it's not a small
medieval times it's a big medieval times
and then they do jousting there's food
still I thought it was like a90s no no
the Knights of the Templar Justice dude
they still have regular J oh yeah she
was extracurricular activity in it right
stupid and from there all right
everybody knows this song is one of
those things that hits the top [__]
charts every single year if she B
somewhere around $2 million a year on it
yeah yeah just from the end of the year
the Christmas imagine if 12 months they
played it yeah she's she's already like
in like gotten maybe like 70 million
total gross on it or something just off
of one song that's something dude by the
way if Joe wrote All I want for
Christmas is you that's his mentality
he'd be like how do we make Christmas
every month
we all know that's true how do we
stretch it to J how do we 12x Christmas
day you know what's crazy fun fact in
[__] Europe they stretch out the
Christmas Market past Christmas it goes
past how far past
Christmas we start post Halloween
realistic yeah that's true we do a
little bit of that but officially I
think after Black Friday is official
Yeah official yeah no actually it's
after Halloween nowadays they're making
it much earlier no it's not after Black
Friday it is Black Friday because that's
after Thanksgiving and that's Black
Friday is Christmas shopping M you know
who really does it the most the
Filipinos um one of my employees she's
from the Philippines right and then she
goes we do Christmas on all the bur
months and I was like what's a bur month
September October November December
January February you know why March B
you know why they do it why so they
don't have to eat the food for 4 months
they can make turkey ham wow right SC
potato what a release so the song's
cowriter right the song's co-writer
Walter aasf or whatever he recently
claimed that the singer had been telling
tall tales about the invention of the
song All right so the way Mariah Carey
talks about it recently all right is
that basically as a kid on my little
Casio Keyboard you know she was coming
up with the track according to a 2017
interview on Billboard and then in her
Memoir in 2020 the meeting of Mariah
care she said uh actually did bang out
most of it on uh most of the song on a
cheap little Casio keyboard so she's
sticking to this concept of the story
whereas this dude Walter talking on an
episode on a podcast somewhere he claims
that Carrie started making up these
falsehoods about the origin of the song
in the recent decade he said we were
both on the same page about how we wrote
All I want for Christmas is you there
was never any alternate story until
probably 10 years ago when she started
to hint the fact that oh I wrote that
song when I was a little girl but he's
like why weren't you saying that for the
12 or3 or 15 years prior to that so it
just sort of developed in her mind yeah
why is he trying to [__] up a good thing
this like he's so dumb this precious
story is great marketing for the song
makes people want to tune in more and
he's getting paid from it and [__] it
all up he I'm sure he get royalties
right well maybe he's Rich enough or
doesn't give give a [__] and it's about
Legacy at that point nah no one knows
about it's in the writing credits shut
the [__] up nobody knew his name until
today yeah but no one cares do you know
who Bill finger is who's that so Bob
Kane did Batman right right he's the
creater Batman Bill Finger also did
Batman but nobody knows that why cuz he
was not good he wasn't that
good no it's cuz he didn't get any
[__] credit and and he he died poor
basically died pennes this guy's in the
credits though right so that's why I
agree I agree with Joe shut the [__] up
got you're getting paid now she has a
little cute little story that makes
people want to tune in even more so get
paid even more but then now it's going
to be like oh that guy's a [__] dick
actually listen to it I don't want to
know that some XCOM murderers from a
bakery shop made this because they can't
get a decent job they have to work in a
factory I want to believe that elves
made these cookies and then [__]
packaged it nicely elves conv and then
hey these these sugar cookies they came
from the [__] fingers of a [__] elf
you know that's what I want to know
that's what I need to know even smaller
elf yep right yeah
Aid smaller one I to know it came from
the
kids
a handy cane
Factory a bunch of
hbas cute as [__] dude with their little
hands making ice so cute or do you want
to see a thug [__] face tattooed Thug
with a hair net that's making this [__]
regular height hairnet murder hands or
elf hands murder hands thank you jeez
exactly sorry Anthony what were you
saying so he goes on to say she doesn't
play anything she doesn't play keyboard
or piano she doesn't music she doesn't
know chord changes in Music Theater oh
he sounds like a hater bro she doesn't
know a diminish does matter minor
seventh chord to so [__] what oh my
God who gives a [__] shut up shut up
Anthony don't yell at me I'm
not Christmas is here with the little
[__] elves with me okay sorry my bad I
just got worked up hit him with some
excaliber facts oh the couples what's
are cross
streets Las Vegas and not Spring
Mountain I don't know okay well as long
as no no no but find but find out with
your head right now with MGM uh What uh
cuz right across T Gordo is there is it
Tropicana yeah maybe trop trop Tropic
stop playing the game Anthony you're
supposed to get mad at this hey I'm not
Walter okay Walter alak what's his name
yeah so she doesn't even know what to
diminish I hate when people use Music
knowledge elitism to like invalidate
someone else's success that's so dumb
she made a banger reminds me she's not
even a real singer she's just slip
syncing the whole time he he says so to
claim that she wrote a very complicated
chord structured song is it a
complicated corduck it doesn't matter
what she did with her [__] career is
way harder than this it doesn't matter
that's the rock you know what I you know
what I think about is is these guys they
wanted to be the star but they were too
[__] ugly that's why they had to go
in the back stay in the [__] back of
the bakery and make the cookie like you
know like that's what they had to have
and don't leave until the lights are off
you're too ugly it like a lot of there
are a lot of see I told you look like
Joe pants he looks like a guy on
Jeopardy that ends the game with
Z you know like the dumb thing is that
it with a lot of Ghost Riders my a lot
of Ghost Riders there's there's like an
ingredient there's this classic NDA
where they're like hey I'm going to say
whatever the [__] I want about how this
song got made and you just get money
yeah yeah that's it I'm sure he's
getting paid right well if he's not then
I totally okay I can understand if he's
mad but if he's not getting paid yeah
how are you not get some bangers though
so he did
uh uh what is it hosting H you're you're
host jacking no no no NOP no no sorry
cuz at first I was like who the [__] is
this loser now he's backing me up no hyp
mentality ain't nobody heard this
[__] before but he did uh
Endless Love with Luther van Ross oh
[__] One Sweet Day Mariah Carey boy to
man yeah he's done a [__] load of Music
czy Banger he's the brains behind
probably so much K G Earth fire glad so
I can understand maybe then if he's
already at like gangster level like
iconic music and then suddenly like 10
years in halfway into the LIF stand of
the song this person who you co-wrote it
with starts changing the story of where
it came up I could understand being like
yo slow your R like you're making an
extra million every CH he has [__] you
money he doesn't care he's just telling
the truth now now I get it yeah but it's
silly to think that that's not something
she's supposed to do as a pop star like
they're all doing that with everything
they do not just the songs it's part of
the business every part of their life
like does it change anything that
Jenny's not really from the Block to you
you're a musician you need to stand up
for the musicians what are you doing
that's the thing though but then I'm
also a musician that would be down to
sign an and that like hey say whatever
the hell you want say you learned this
in an African village you wrote this in
70 seconds right what's a more
compelling story a more compelling story
you wrot this homeless I was a kid and I
was listening to something and it
inspired me and I P my shoes and I had
this song in my heart or [__] I was
with this fat [__] ball [__] in a
studio and we were just like
going and then it he told me to do it in
diminish seven and then and then we from
here like no one [__] cares all I
want for Christmas is
you the exact cords if he didn't get
paid to play along then that's messed up
but if you're getting paid to play along
just play along that's a boring story
though yeah boring St they're all boring
stories that's the thing all the stories
are he's also he's also coming after
insiration behind this song uh my
[__] riter came up with it and then
the the producer made the beat and then
they had me sing this in the studio yeah
that's going to be every story like
Justin Bieber's Discovery truly is a
boring story but it's way cooler for
kids to think that they just found them
like singing and Usher was like hey I
like this kid that's not the real story
oh no no honey
it was a media campaign yeah he already
had a manager at that point oh snap was
it scooter Bron yeah oh snap but then
see that's that's the genius of scooter
Bron that he's also willing to you know
he's not say I made him yeah scooter
Bron's also willing to play along with
whatever you know it's going to sell
[__] you
mother